non penso che non usavo cleverbot e
volevo fare un altro video su cleverbot
anche perché riguardo che le
conversazioni passate erano proprio over
the top
proviamoci heigl è verbo ti ricordi di
me è la prima volta che si impieghi
risposta veloce ma a questo punto
mettiamo dalla prova allora se ti
ricordi davvero chi sono
non riesco a capire ma chi tua madre
non capisco no mio tu sei il mio schiavo
sono tempo per cambiare gameplay
possiamo fare un altra roba è diventato
un pervertito sto tizio non s'ha da un
momento all'altro non era così una volta
ve lo giuro proviamo gimmo ragazzi a
questo punto ti ricordi di me no chi sei
sono fa vj non è vero hai sentito la mio
fratello questo scherzo ragazzi come fai
ad essere veramente cosa centra fa dj
sono io cioè il mio nome era per farti
capire chi sono
non è vero cosa sono
sono davvero solo j.craig di madonna ti
adoro grazie grazie grazie
ho finalmente l'ha capito poteva anche
schemi che ti fa ci stimolano ne vede
ecco appunto cosa ne pensi di fa vj che
va bè ragazzi basta un claim quanto mi
quanto mi è mancato questo sito ciao
bella io ti conosco sono un maschio la
chirurgia fa passi da gigante comunque
come ti chiamavi prima dell'operazione
capite perché io non ho più fatto sta
roba perché non ha senso di esistere
federico
ti ricordi di me bo come ti chiami fa vj
fatemi capire se qualcuno si ricorda
allora 66 fa di quanti video hai fatto
di su motori di reims mi chiama che
domanda ma che ne so ma non mi ricordo
sia o ne avrò fatti 10 non sarà di sei
ridicolo ma tua madre ma se sei un rubat
non solo sono fa vj loro loro difficile
capire che stai parlando
veramente si sono favi j
ho davvero io allora dimmi il tuo vero
nome se serif abili è un genio perché se
io gli dico il mio vero nome allora vuol
dire che sono famiglie e cioè nel senso
nessun altro può sapere il mio nome
tranne me il mio vero nome è lorenzo ma
mi chiama quanti anni hai e due i sei
maschio femmina guardate me lo sono
chiesto anche io e molto spesso
e allora cosa ci sono una marionetta
sono una marionetta ia ia ia oh no a
conoscerla bellissimo
9 grande sono un marchio allora tina su
frey
le mostre i pettorali questo non lo
accetto che si forma mi sento così solo
che lì a pietro zio non voglio parlare
con una ragazza appunto chiede a pietro
le mostra il codice ma a letto con l
innocente ma cosa ti spinge avanti cose
forse sì che può comunque lei ai
pettorali quindi non è che ci sia tanto
da vantarsi sono andata a letto
lei ha fatto dormire insieme è stato
l'atto sessuale più veloce del mondo ti
è piaciuto sciate un sacco ti piacerebbe
incontrarmi questa spinge forte dove
vuoi che ci incontriamo alessio a casa
mia perché vuoi andare a casa tua
perché lì c'è un mare bello e
pulitissimo cercato seis pongo cosa vuoi
fare a caso spiega mi voglio andare
sopra di te si gioca a rimpiattino a
java me cosa ti piace di me
i tuoi piedi la tua faccia i miei piedi
ti piacciono i miei piedi 6 feticista 6
feticista o mio dio si sa bene ti
piacciono i miei piedi anche votato nei
numeri è neanche mai visi mm tanto mm a
questo punto raga visto che abbiamo
fatto cleverbot abbiamo fatto e vie
abbiamo fatto veramente tutto
diamo anche un'occhiata si richieda un
po che non la tocco come una volta
registravo anche quello che facevo
consigli adesso non c'ho voglia subito
youtuber pigro quindi nel caso vi faccio
vedere così ciao fini non ci sentiamo da
un bel po come stai
meravigliosamente o mi fa piacere che mi
racconti di bello conosco una favola sul
mare che dice così il marinaio spiegò le
vele al vento ma evento non capì posso
farti una domanda
certo che tutto quello che vuoi puoi
andartene
ecco un posto che corrisponde a [ __ ]
non sembra di stare molto da dove ti
trovi
ma negli anni regrediscono di robot
invece di migliorare la tecnologia non
capisco una sega raga fermi tutti prova
a cambiare lingua mettere il giapponese
home l'ua machine dei capisco
ma si può imbattere note star
ho lavorato duramente l'ultima volta
lattici spulciare avere un dialogo con
una scimmia sarebbe stato più
intelligente di sta roba però va bè
ragazzi basta consigli basta con i robot
basta con tutto vero che vi sia piaciuto
il video era da un po che non facevo né
cyrine viene cleverbot però voluto
riportarli una volta solo per vedere che
cosa sarebbe uscito fuori era meglio non
lo facevo comunque ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto cosa ci fu il momento mi
piace anche ai vari social come di
tradizione se non siete ancora iscritti
iscrivetevi
se non siete a quelli siti iscrivetevi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video verrà
ragazzi 2017 fottuti robot
[Musica]